what made you decide in the beginning to
get involved rescuing kids
well I I I was my first job at the CIA I
was there through 9 11 and when I
learned about Muhammad attah who was a
terrorist across over the Border uh
Mexico into the U.S and then and then
launched his attack I want to be on that
border so I I trained anti-trafficient
anti-terrorism stuff I have a graduate
degree in a certificate in
anti-terrorism so I got put on that
border that's where I wanted to be I
speak Spanish six months later they
asked me to be in the group child crimes
I said no so there's no way I'm going to
go in that group
um and my wife's agreed with me and then
the next morning before I said no she
she didn't sleep all night she was
crying and she said we have to say yes
oh my gosh if how can we be so fearful
of our own pain
uh that uh that we would disregard
severe pain beyond our comprehension